that random white dude you had on your
podcast that i think you're beefing with
now
uh oh
bro he's homeless
that dude like you did you guys did that
interview yeah and then he started dming
me like
every day
like yo yo i was on adam 22 let me come
up and
i was like yeah bro i'm i'm good you
know like and then the dude just started
like bashing me on his instagram yo he
does that to everybody it's honestly
he's like
he kills me mental condition yeah
because he's scared of you but he like
uh he like really like does that to
everybody that does anything for him
because i like
no matter how much he asked him he
couldn't come up with anything that i
did to him to make him upset he just
tripped out
so i mean
honestly he's a lost soul is there has
there been that situation for you where
you've like because i feel like you know
you look at like
the crit mac dude who i feel like
is his own
thing now he's like like yeah and and i
first obviously saw him and his
personality and how funny he was on no
jumper
has there been a situation where you
feel like you've
kind of helped
bring people you know some attention
that they might not have otherwise
gotten
but but the second that something
doesn't necessarily go their way they
they they get combative with you
honestly like there's been so many
people where when i look at it i kind of
i don't say like i gave them a career
because everybody like you know [ __ ]
mack was who he was in the first place i
just helped to shine a light on it and
then you know channel five does content
with him and that shines a big ass light
on him et cetera you know that's just
it's not like i [ __ ] invented him or
made him or anything like that but yeah
like almost all the time people are
really cool about that and like you know
they see that for what it is and they're
appreciative of the fact that you help
them to get somewhere you're not going
to do the whole thing for them obviously
there's a lot of work for you to do once
you get your no jumper interviewer you
get your vlad interview but we see it
all the time where you know i see so
many older gangster dudes or even like
you know people in other ways of life
who've been on vlad a couple times and
then all of a sudden you fast forward a
couple years and they use that to launch
their own podcast and they all of a
sudden have a big old revenue stream and
a business for themselves and that's a
beautiful thing you know and like
i would you know almost everybody like
sees that dynamic and respects and
appreciates it milk is the rare
[ __ ] who basically like
sees that and doesn't like get it he's
like oh you did something for me but
you're not gonna keep doing things for
me so now i hate you
where like anybody with common sense
would be like oh you did something for
me
i'm gonna stay on good terms with you
because like you'll because i would have
kept [ __ ] with him i would have kept
you know this is why i don't like beef
is crazy i mean he's just like you're
looking at a dude who i mean he told me
about in the interview obviously like a
super [ __ ] up childhood and i don't
think he like knows how to be loved he
doesn't know how to like have somebody
do something nice for him and then
return that and reciprocate and like
have a healthy
bond between people because you're
talking about somebody that has no
friends he's not like respected or like
allowed back where he's from et cetera
none of those people [ __ ] with him at
all it's like i mean it's pretty
transparent like if you watch his
content or whatever that he doesn't have
any relationships you know